hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in the proma to any future
metaphysics Emmanuel K Begins the second
part of the transcendental question
which is subtitled how is is pure
Natural Science possible by going into a
few different understandings of what
nature could be and then talking about
what this pure Natural Science would
actually be and consistent and he's
going to formulate that question how is
this in fact possible after noting that
not only is it possible but it it exists
and so it's not a question of whether
it's possible it's a question of well
how and what are we talking about here
so we begin with thinking about nature
itself and he begins this section by
saying nature is the existence of things
the design right of things in so far as
it is
determined by universal laws and that's
you know not typically how we would
begin in a Rough and Ready naive way if
somebody ask us what's nature we're like
well you know trees and animals and the
air and going outside and stuff like
that and Kant isn't looking for that
sort of answer he wants to know what is
essential what is characteristic of
everything that we call nature and even
the things that we consider to be
artificial are in a certain sense nature
because we're part of nature as well so
the existence the design of things
determined btim right by Universal laws
and that's a concept that he's going to
use over and over again and then he
opposes to it another possible and quite
prevalent understanding of what nature
would mean he says should nature signify
the existence the doign again of things
in themselves D
an right so getting to what it is that
lies behind the appearances what lies
behind the experiences that we have
what's what's the real stuff the
metaphysics right uh he says well if
that was the case then we would have
some problems and we're going to get to
that in a bit but we do want to throw
that idea out there and then he's going
to bring up a little bit later another
conception of nature that that goes
along with the first one he says that it
is the
totality the
in of all objects of experience so
everything not only that we do
experience but everything that is
potentially out there conceived as a
whole this is the way that he talks
about it in its
material aspect right now we can't
ever experience the tot ality of Nature
and we have a hard time even imagining
it or even cognizing it in a clear way
but it it is a conception that we can
have now why can't nature be the things
in themselves that then we would you
know in some way get to through
philosophy or through uh some scientific
experiments and then assemble into you
know some sort of coherent framework
that we typically call laws so he
says well if nature signified the
existence of things in themselves we
could never cognize it either a priori
or a posteriori so he's setting up a
dilemma here where are you going to get
this conception of the things in
themselves from are you going to get it
a priori a priori means prior to and
independent of any experience so a says
well how can we know what belongs to
things in themselves because this can't
be done by the dissection of our
Concepts that is in analytic judgments
judgments that uh don't really add
anything new how are we going to get
something new out of them we're not
going to so we can't just engage in
analysis of what we think and he says I
don't want to know what is contained in
my concept of a thing that belongs to
its logical being but what in the
actuality the
viite the reality of the thing is super
added to my concept and by which the
thing itself is determined in its
existence outside the concept so you
know we've got Concepts in our heads we
want to know what do these
Concepts actually signify in reality in
actuality and and we can't we can't get
to that not analytically not a priori so
what about a posteriori by way of
experience he goes on and he says that
um a cognition of the nature of things
in themselves a
posteriori would be equally impossible
why if experience is to teach us laws to
which the existence of things is subject
these laws if they refer to things in
themselves would to refer to them of
necessity even
outside of our experience so how are you
going to get something nonexperiential
hyper physical as he's going to call it
a little bit later on
from contingent experience how are we
going to get necessity OPP odicity from
from this or we're not going to he says
experience teaches us what exists great
and how it exists but not or actually
never he says that it must necessarily
exist so and not otherwise experience
cannot teach us the nature of things in
themselves so not only is Kant setting
down a limit here he's saying that's the
wrong direction to go if you actually
want to understand nature so we don't
want to think of nature as the things in
themselves we want to think of it as
what it is that we can actually
experience and place under
laws what are we concerned with here he
distinguishes a little bit later between
a formal aspect which corresponds to the
first um characteriz characterization
the existence of things determined by
universal laws so the formal aspect of
nature is its Conformity to law
gazette's messy kite in German right so
and and The Gazette mess kite of the gag
of the objects of our experience so that
is one key thing and then he says that
uh nature considered materiality ter is
the totality of all objects of
experience and with this only Are We Now
concerned by contrast to things in
themselves he says um things that can
never be objects of experience if they
were to be cognized as to their nature
would oblige us to have recourse to
Concepts whose meaning could never be
given in concreto in
actuality by any example of possible
experience so if we're going to go
beyond this we would have to form for
ourselves a list of concepts of their
nature the reality whereof could never
be determined and we want to determine
we want to be able to say this fits over
here here's how the law works that's
what determination means in this sort of
uh operation and he says that so these
wouldn't be an object of experience but
they would be hyper physical we're not
interested in that he's not saying there
can't be anything hyper physical he's
just saying if we're doing a study of
nature we don't want to go beyond nature
and notice that he doesn't say
metaphysical he talks about hyper
physical in this point so K says we
actually do have something that we can
call a universal
alamina Natural Science right so what
does this actually look like he talks
about two parts to this but he's mostly
interested in the physical part
psychological stuff can come in later
but it does point out that we have these
two sides to it based on what kind of
sense we're looking at we have the
external senses we have the world as we
experience it through our perception and
as we're going to see a little bit later
on what else is coming along with our
perception and then we have inner sense
we don't just have the exterior senses
we have what it is that we experience if
we want to be a little bit metaphorical
in our own head
right and so one of these is going to be
physics the world of external things the
well our bodies as well and then the
other will be psychology the laws of the
mind and you might say well how does
this fit into Natural Science this is a
way that that Kant conceives of nature
right so if it's subject to laws and
it's something that we can experience we
experience our own mental states don't
we we don't experience directly those of
others but we assume that they're
happening too so we can we can uh talk
about this as two different sides he is
very interested in physics which he says
is founded on empirical principles and
what is this he calls this
mathematics applied to ex to
appearances right and also merely
discursive principles now discursive
principles
grun right so a zat is a proposition it
can also be you know senten is whatever
you want grun are these fundamental
propositions that we're going to see uh
called something else very shortly and
so um you know what we're interested in
here is not just applying mathematics
which now we've already got is pure
mathematics uh you know
AR priori apodictic deductive applied to
the appearances that we have but also
these discursive and that's just a
transliteration of the German discursive
principles that are applied to these
objects right so that's that's pretty
important he also talks about laws to
which nature is subject right
Den State so literally under which or
under the rubric of which nature as as a
whole and as our experiences of of it is
located state staying right so this is
important stuff this is what Universal
natural science is supposed to give us
and he says that this is the
philosophical part of the pure cognition
of
nature he also says there's much in it
which is not quite pure and independent
of empirical sources like the concept of
motion impenetrability inertia right
which prevent it from being called a
quite pure transcendental Natural
Science and it's referring to you know
objects of of the external sense as we
see here but what we get among the
principles the zets right of this
Universal physics he tells us that there
are some which are universal laws of
nature not gazet which subsist
completely a priori so they apply to
experience the empirical the aposteriori
but they are a priori they are prior to
that and we can figure out what they are
and we have indeed figured out some of
them already he's going to give us a few
examples here the propositions that
substance is permanent right now you
could actually say to yourself well
that's probably an analytic sort of
judgment isn't it isn't that just rolled
into the notion of substance itself
great where the hell did you get this
notion from right at some point in time
we had to have according to Kant some
sort of AR
priori concept that we're bringing in
that applies to this set of uh possible
you know statements about objects of
experience and can be universalized into
a law of nature what's another one every
event is determined by a cause according
to constant laws right and he's going to
talk about that one a little bit later
as well because he's going to raise this
question how is it that we have this
pure natural science
or how can we cognize a priori that
things as objects of experience
necessarily conformed to law how is it
possible to cognize oper prior the
necessary Conformity to law of
experience itself as regards all of its
objects generally these are ways of
reformulating this this fundamental
question and he says you know uh if we
want the solution to this we can think
of the uh uh he says the solution uh
amounts to the pure cognition of nature
entirely to the same thing the
subjective laws under which alone an
empirical cognition of things is
possible hold good of these things as
objects of possible experience so he
says either the following statements
means the
same a judgment of perception can never
rank as experience without the law that
whenever an event is observed it's
always referred to some antecedent which
it follows according to a universal rule
causality right or else everything of
which experience teaches that it happens
must have a cause and he
says these are essential equivalent but
we want to take the first
formulation why because the other one is
too tempting to us to do metaphysics
right or hyperphysics in this case he
says that uh we can a priori have a
cognition of conditions on which alone
experience of them is possible but never
of laws to which things may in
themselves be subject without reference
to possible experience so we can't study
the nature of things a priori EX except
by studying the conditions and universal
laws uh though they're subjective under
which such Co a cognition as experience
is possible and this is what the stuff
that follows is doing for Pure physics
he says if I choose the second formula
and I start looking for op prior
conditions under which nature as an
object of experience is possible I might
easily fall into error and F fancy that
I was speaking of nature as a thing of
it in itself and then I'm just going to
go round and round and not make any
progress so this is how Kant
conceptualizes nature and the science
the discipline which a priori would be
able to provide us with laws that must
apply to anything that we can possibly
experience